it's like you're it's like you're Alfred
Hitchcock yes [ __ ]
wait what are we gonna do yeah that was
literally it and love my future like I
not supposed to be a sequel I think we
both when they came back and out when
Lionsgate came back and asked us to do
though and we said we're interested it's
great but just give us a little time
again our big thing is we just don't
want to suck and we've seen a lot of
sequels go downhill especially in the
action genre so we're like look we made
a deal with each other if we can come up
with something in a couple of weeks that
we're really exciting someone we're
gonna give up a year and a half of our
life for we'll do it if we can't then
we'll handle path and I don't know if it
was like a couple weeks yeah we're
married
thunder rolls offices cannot where the
idea of the marker and kind of like
blood stay with the guy that's fallen to
see what he's gonna do let's reverse the
whole thing on I'm like now that he's in
that's triggered thing and I think
you're the one that came in with a
consequence to stay with the fate thing
and if the first movie didn't happen the
second one didn't happen and then we
decided well let's have it happen the
next day I think he just like this whole
thing has causes ripple effect you
working again
I'll see you
like yeah
me room like all right that's awesome
we'll have a bulletproof suit we'll do
it and we just started started tumbling
out we had this list of ideas no script
but idea isn't like all right this is
resources character I'm a music because
I was sorry my John could sign language
John could speak Italian so after like a
week of just riffing and we just
realized that we're open to everything
every time we talked about it was just
like now we started giggling gone this
is ridiculous we said okay we'll do what
style
tell you how many buttons to travels us
tapered how about the line in tactical
favorite fight scene chapter two gosh I
mean I mean I've got favourites on
different levels right like I think the
pencil fight it had we had to do the
pencil fight because of John wick II
can't I'm and I see my pencil the pencil
I was so I kill three men in a bar with
the Benson who the [ __ ] can do that and
you like to sumo I just like that little
montage
that's my tricky little wife but the
mirror room is my all-time now I love
the setup of the common fight in the
subway I love that kind of 6070 s kind
of hard-boiled and then the common fight
for aficionados is pretty pretty tasty
gentlemen well I mean while we were
doing some of the things it's it's like
okay so how is John gonna what Bowery
King the underground walking around
scouting a lot of towns
really familiar with New York and I was
trying to familiarize ourselves more
with New York and you walked around and
he saw you know some of the homeless and
semi stuff and it's like if you had to
be an assassin we just rationalize like
and you wanted no one to notice you that
would be the guy I'd pick like no one
notices and that would be the when they
hear and see everything but people are
normally like what a great analog way to
be your NSA or CIA or the city to be
that and we started thinking about I
don't think you came Bowery King like
king of the Bowery okay and that just
clicked and like you know you hear the
voice already in your head obviously and
it was kind of a no-brainer choice it
was like let's call the hornet's
Fishburne Laurence Fishburne
what's the number up to now our oh seven
million dollars damn it's Christmas
we're going to Applebee's after this
yeah each one's got a vibe you know from
ridiculous to font like the night fares
for me is just fun and interesting but
like the the glass we're going with Shep
Shep and Yan is really fun and then Bo
bond is a blast for me yeah you know I
love the underwater and I have a million
we get we get notices that people are
fans like little hints I mean just Halle
searching like she searched us out and
said she'd really like to be part of it
and we're you can't get more flatter
than that I mean that's pretty that's
pretty cool it's Sophia we're not going
in like the old days just a conversation
nothing's ever just a conversation with
you John yeah that moment with guns lots
of guns in the in the script the
original line was Gardens and is it your
idea yeah dunno March today yeah homage
to the 20th anniversary of the matrix
yeah groans lots of Girl Talk Keanu went
to giving it one go one take what do you
need guns
it's a little meta you know it's I mean
I think that's kind of modern I mean
there's always been kind of nods to
things yeah we try to put a little that
every John wake about what we're we're
really influenced by personal I don't
know I think they'd have to have a
technical part of that I think there
should be like a technical and then
there should and then I think you would
have to go in to the right word
people love ya know I love the idea of
it having been a stunt performer and all
that stuff in a stuck part in an action
director it's tricky because a lot
action is a big group effort more so I
think than any other department we
combined all seven or eight departments
together the director comes up with
ideas secondly the special effects guy I
mean I think if you needed a technical
or war would be great and then an
individual achievement based on
creativity how to apply it to the story
would be interesting but there's so much
influence like you can get a stunt
coordinator and then the choreographer
does the work or you need a
choreographer that's okay and the
director influences the style then the
editor does all the cunning like I've
seen great action done but then lost in
a director's cut or loss in the Edit or
a director comes up with a great idea
and maybe it's shot incorrectly so I
don't know it's still tricky it's still
a big thing in the stunt community right
now who would get the award and how you
would marginalize that but then if we
went in front of the curve down back
onto the big screen and it would be like
okay what what action sequence people
were like yeah I think that's the way I
mean channels got a good point that's
the way I'd have to judge it what I made
it to screen this is awesome how did it
make you feel you stood up and [ __ ]
cheered or close your eyes I think
that's worth an award on any level
all of this for what because of a puppy
wasn't just a puppy
[Music]